these are GPS markers of liquid natural
gas tankers in the English Channel many
are idling or sailing slowly much like
this other cluster in the Gulf of cadith
off the coast of Spain
each of these ships is carrying enough
liquefied natural gas to heat a million
homes a month but they can unload their
cargo at least not right now but lots at
stake the economy would really nose dive
if stalls of gas were to run out so
what's Behind These tanker traffic jams
and what might they mean for Europe's
energy needs this winter
European nations are racing to store
natural gas a commodity the continent
relies on to fuel its factories power
its cities and heat its homes
the recent supply chain bottlenecks
threatened to undermine Europe's energy
security
until recently Europe relied on Russia
for about 40 percent of the natural gas
it used to heat its homes and power its
Industries but this year's Russian war
in Ukraine threw Europe into its biggest
energy crisis since the 1970s before the
war about half of the Russian gas that
ended up in Europe via pipeline was
transported by the nordstream 1 pipeline
which runs under the Baltic Sea
connecting Russia's Siberian gas fields
to Germany but in June Russian gas giant
gas prom began reducing gas flows
through the pipeline we are working on
the worst possible scenario then in
September Russian indefinitely suspended
natural gas flows to Europe via
Nordstrom later that month European
authorities released footage of the
Baltic Sea bubbling amid reports of
unexplained leaks from the nordstream
pipelines it was a deliberate Act of
sabotage Putin has launched Russia's
first mobilization since World War II
and since many months he is using energy
as a weapon Western governments and
intelligence agencies haven't yet named
a suspected culprit with the pipelines
no longer operational European leaders
have turned to other countries like the
United States and Qatar to supply the
continent's natural gas but rebuilding
Europe's natural gas supply chain hasn't
been easy to begin with there are not
enough regasification terminals for the
tankers to offload their gas
regasication terminals are huge plants
built on the coastline they take in
electrified natural gas tankers they
turn that liquid gas back into a gas and
pump it into the domestic Network there
are quite a few of them in Europe but
they're not distributed evenly you have
a lot in the UK and Spain and in
Portugal you don't have any at all in
Germany compounding the issue is a lack
of storage Europe simply does not have
enough space to keep the gas Europe does
have a lot of gas in storage it stores
gas in Caverns underground and in tanks
for the past half century Europe has
been able to rely on a very steady
supply of Russian gas so there was no
need to build even bigger get storage
facilities for now many of these giant
ships are serving as temporary offshore
gas storage facilities which has
resulted in part from a market Dynamic
known as contango contango is a
technical term used by Traders for a
situation where a commodity costs less
if the trader sells it tomorrow than it
costs if the trader agrees to sell it in
several months time and it's a way in
which the market encourages traders to
hold on to a commodity such as gas to
store it for when it is needed later in
the year or early next year
this chart tracks the difference between
liquid natural gas prices next month
compared to prices in two months time as
you can see on September 15th a Trader
would make 3.42 cents per million
British thermal units if they held their
tanker at Sea until November rather than
if they offloaded the gas in October a
month later on October 13th that Gap had
more than doubled to about seven dollars
and fifty cents per million British
thermal units if they sold in December
rather than in November the original
Target was to fill storage facilities to
80 percent of their total capacity by
November 1st that Target has been met
and exceeded far ahead of schedule the
latest data suggests storage is now at
nearly 95 percent in total European
natural gas prices have plunged more
than 70 percent since hitting an
all-time high in late August after
storage facilities across the continent
filled close to capacity but there isn't
enough storage to get through winter if
several things go wrong for example if
it's very cold
if Russian supplies stop altogether and
if suppliers from Norway or the US get
disrupted in some way
[Music]